you're listening to an encore
presentation of Bible answers live the
phone number to join the program and ask
your questions is not available this
evening however if you want to order any
materials offered during tonight's
program you may call our resource number
anytime at $887 live
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the Word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 885 6 7 4 7
once again that's 800 eight three five
six seven four seven now here's your
host from amazing facts international
pastor Doug Batchelor hi friends would
you like to hear an amazing fact munsi
moosa king of the Mali Empire during the
14th century was the first African ruler
to be widely known throughout Europe in
the Middle East during his reign he
ruled over the most productive gold
mines in Africa and controlled the
lucrative salt trade many historians
believe he may have been the richest
person to have ever lived a devout
Muslim he's famous for his 1,400 mile
Hajj pilgrimage to Mecca in the years
1324 and 1325 his Caravan is said to
have consisted of 60,000 people carrying
supplies in baggage 500 slaves each
carrying a gold-plated staff and up to a
hundred camels that were carrying 300
pounds of gold dust it's reported that
when he stopped every Friday for the
Muslim holy day while on his pilgrimage
to Mecca he ordered that a mosque be
built on the spot on his journey
Mansa Musa also stopped at multiple
locations such as Timbuktu Cairo Medina
historians say that he gave away so much
gold to the poor
it caused hyperinflation in these cities
and the value of gold collapsed for a
decade it's estimated that during his
reign
Mansa Musa was worth about 900 billion
dollars in today's currency did you know
the Bible talks about another Kingdom
that had much more gold than the Mali
Empire stay with his friends were going
to learn more in this edition of Bible
answers live you're listening to Bible
answers live accurate and practical
answers to your Bible questions welcome
friends the Bible answers live if you've
got a Bible related question we have
open phone lines now is a good time to
call with your Bible question and it's a
free phone call here is the number 800
god says that's the acronym and here's
the number 800 four six three seven two
nine seven you give a call now good
chance your question will be on
tonight's program any question related
to the Word of God the Bible or living
the Christian life we welcome and we'll
do our best we don't have all the
answers but we've got some good Bible
resources at our fingertips eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven
we're also streaming if you've got a
Facebook account you can simply go to
the Doug Batchelor Facebook page or the
amazing facts Facebook page and you'll
see what's happening here visually as
well as being able to call in your
question my name is Doug Batchelor
frames and pastor Doug as we always do
let's stop the program with prayer your
father once again we thank you that we
were able to open up your word and study
together and we ask your blessing to be
with us here in the studio and those who
are listening across the country and
even around the world and Lord lead us
it's a clearer understanding what the
Bible teaches in Jesus name Amen amen
pastor that you opened the program
talking about a very wealthy King of
course he looked back in the 1300s but
if you were to add up his value back
then and translated that into dollars
today that would definitely make him the
wealthiest man alive yeah if you were to
add up what we know about the wealth of
Warren Buffett and Bill Gates and Jeff
Bezos and many others all of them
combined together many times over does
not equal 900 billion dollars it's just
a phenomenal amount but you know I
believe it because you can read in the
Bible there was a king who lived after
David he's famous is the
the son of David named Solomon and it
tells us that during the reign of
Solomon that there were so much gold in
the kingdom and you've got to keep in
mind that part of it is through trade
Solomon controlled the center bridge
between three continents there in the
Land of Israel his empire was probably
the most vast during the days of
Israel's history but it reached down
into Egypt in Africa up into Asia and
over towards Europe in the Middle East
and and all of the trade routes they
couldn't go across the desert that was
to their east they went through the
Jordan Valley and he got a tariff of
everything that went through and it
tells us that he had ships with the
Phoenicians that went to offer and they
got gold tells us the average income of
gold for Solomon was six hundred and one
it's an interesting number 666
talents of gold and you figure that out
at a Gyptian
talent seventy-five pounds it's about
fifty thousand pounds of gold a year so
but that still is not nine hundred
billion but when you look in the Bible
it does talk about another King and
another Kingdom he read in Revelation 21
verse 18 speaking of the New Jerusalem
in heaven the construction of its walls
was find of Jasper and the city was pure
gold like clear glass there were twelve
gates and there were twelve pearls each
individual gate was one pearl and the
streets of the city were pure gold like
transparent glass talking about a lot of
gold and wealthy Kingdom there was no
earthly Kingdom that will ever compare
with the kingdom that God has prepared
for those that love him now folks don't
have problems believing that there was a
king named Mansa Musa who had sixty
thousand people that joined him on a
pilgrimage but some people struggle
believing that God has this city that
he's prepared and I don't know why I
believe everything else in the Bible you
can believe what it says about heaven
and he is building a place for you we
have a free offer that talks about that
a book off free offer this evening is
called heaven is it for real and it
deals with this
wonderful truth that God is preparing a
place for those that love him will be
happy to send this to anyone who calls
and asks you just need to call out
resource phone line not a phone line
which is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven and you can ask for
the book called heaven is it for real
we'll be happy to send that to you again
that's 800 eight three five six seven
four seven and if you have a Bible
question our phone line here to the
studio is 800 four six three seven two
nine seven and looks like we have some
lines open it's a good time to pick up
your phone and give us a call that's 800
four six three seven two nine seven
pastor Doug I think we're ready to go to
our first caller we have Mike listening
in st. Louis Missouri Mike welcome to
the program good thank you for calling
well making my question my Bible my
question concerns Hebrews chapter 4
verse 9 this is where we made it
therefore hear us to the people of God
and my question is that I heard that
this is the Christian Sabbath this is
referring to and the Christian Sabbath
is that one thousand year period that
begins with the first resurrection in
the book of Revelation well where in the
Bible would it say the Christian Sabbath
is different from the Sabbath of the ten
commandments I mean everything else in
the Ten Commandments is for Christian
and Jew so you know I wonder sometimes
people say that well under the Christian
dispensation the Ten Commandments are
for the Jews and the Christians have
something different I Sarah well where's
that scripture and I don't see a
scripture anywhere that says that
Christians are exempt from anything
commandments or there's a different one
so back to your question in the Hebrews
chapter 4 when you look in Hebrews 4 and
it says there remains therefore a rest
for the people of God the word rest
there that is used is it's sabot is mos
okay and that's the word that is talking
about the same as the Christian Sabbath
so there's still the keeping of a
Sabbath and you know there's
no question he says a little earlier God
spoke in a certain place of the seventh
day on this race he's talking about the
seventh day Sabbath but he's using the
Sabbath saying when you know the
children of Israel came into the
Promised Land they were to rest from
their journeying their constant
wandering in the wilderness and but
that's temporary because we all get old
and diet but the rest that Jesus offers
us in heaven is an eternal rest but
that's a separate question
you know what Christians all still need
that day where we come together we rest
physically and we worship God we rest
from our work it's one of the
commandments that is still needed today
and very valid ok well I think about
what you said I'm not really sure I'm
kind of confused a little bit but not
much
well can we if you'd let us we'll send
you we have a free resource we can send
you we had a great website that talks
about this subject too it's just called
Sabbath truth calm and you can go there
any time and take a look at it there's a
number of great resources there you know
pastor like one verse that does come to
mind we do have an example in the New
Testament actually in the book of Acts
of Gentile believers also keeping the
Sabbath right and we find this in Acts
chapter 13 verse 42 and I'll just read
it it says when the Jews went out of the
synagogue the Gentiles begged that these
words might be preached to them the next
Sabbath so on the next Sabbath alms the
whole city came together to hear the
word of God so this is Paul preaching
and they were both Jewish believers and
then Gentile believers and they were
keeping the Sabbath they were worshiping
they came together to worship on the
Sabbath mm-hmm well thank you hope that
helps a little bit Mike we appreciate
your question and take a look at that
website
Sabbath truth com next one of the babies
Patrick listening in Canada Toronto
Canada Patrick welcome to the program
how are you good thank you for calling I
like to find out how important and how
often should a Christmas enemies have
worship great question I wish more
people were asking that question let me
read a verse to you from Deuteronomy
chapter 6 verse 6
now chapter 5 of Deuteronomy Moses
repeats the Ten Commandments and then in
chapter 6 he says these words that I
command you today shall be in your heart
you shall teach them diligently that
were diligent levy means you know with
with enthusiasm and energy is Ella Slee
teach them diligently carefully to your
children you'll talk of them when you
sit in your house when you walk by the
way when you lay down that's the evening
when you rise up that's the morning and
so on our family we typically had
morning and evening worship and
sometimes it could be when they're young
you can't make it too long if they get
distracted but you know pray with them
try and give them some verses you get a
little over you can maybe read a
one-page devotional if you make it long
it can become grueling but just let them
know that God is the center of our lives
and commit them to the Lord for the day
and then the end of the day you talk to
them about you know having their hearts
right and if they need to repent but
having worship with your kids every day
and then teaching them to have their own
personal worship their own prayer time
quiet time with God every day it's
important it says otherwise they will
drift and you know of course Solomon
says raise your children up in the way
they should go how do you do that
regular daily worship as well as of
course your weekly worship that you have
with other believers but family worship
very important Abraham wherever he went
he built an altar for his family and
they would offer sacrifice he had the
family worship at every new location he
built an altar thank you this I hope
that helps a little appreciate your
question Patrick and you've got oh
you're welcome you know we also have an
example just one more Bible character
looking here at Jobe Jobe gave an
example of in the morning he would offer
sacrifice on behalf of his family so he
recognized the importance of worship in
the morning and in the evening and that
we see that example throughout the Bible
next caller that we have is Noah
listening from Illinois no welcome to
the program I'm
how how was your guy's evening on good
yeah doing well how about you videos on
YouTube Q well thank you my question is
we know how David's great-grandmother
yes David
it is possible there's no scripture that
tells us one way or the other because it
doesn't tell us the lifespan of Ruth or
Boaz for that matter I don't think it
tells us the lifespan of Boaz in
chronicles but keep in mind David was
the youngest and it also tells us that
when when David was became King Jesse
his father was already an old man Jesse
you know had several sons there's a
little little bit of controversy in that
one place it says that David there were
seven sons of Jesse another place it
says eight but he may have lost one so
but in any event David being the
youngest his great-grandmother would
have been pretty old but it's not
inconceivable that he had met her she
depends on how long she lived wouldn't
that be wonderful to know yeah I I think
we're gonna have to wait to get to
heaven and you know it wasn't very
different from the time of Ruth is also
the time of Salah a Simpson if I
remember correctly when you look in the
judges and she probably had some
interesting stories to tell about the
age that she lived in - Ruth was Samson
there but it's possible there's no
scripture that tells us how old she was
so all we can do is guess okay alright
thank you so much next call to the
behalf is Diane listening from
California Diane welcome in the program
hi thank you so much for taking my call
and thank you for this wonderful program
that you guys have my question is
there's a list of birds and the unclean
animals in the Bible and clean birds and
latex is 11 and Deuteronomy 14 and my
question is how accurate can we rely on
that list as being both accurate to true
to the birds that we have today and also
complete comprehensive you know maybe
there's birds that they had then that we
don't have now and vice versa yeah
specifically I'm wondering about like
turkeys and chickens because most people
think those are clean but I have a hard
time believing that they're clean
because their natural diet is small
reptiles like frogs and snakes and
lizards and and they're so different
from green ever us birds like pigeons
and sparrows and dozen partridges stuff
which I have raised before so I'm just
wondering how that could be yeah well
first of all the some of the birds that
are mentioned there's yeah when you go
from Hebrew to English and these are
very rarely used Hebrew words in the old
in the old language they wonder what was
that was it a pelican was it a swan and
so there's you know there's some
ambiguity but keep in mind when it comes
to the clean and unclean animals there's
a rule for the fish that covers
everything you don't need to know the
name of every fish the rule is if it has
fins and scales needed both conditions
there's a rule for the mammals it needed
to be clovenfooted and shuddha cut to
characteristics to make a mammal clean
for food and then the characteristic for
birds is not given in such a way but
what it does is it kind of establishes a
pattern it the Raptors were called
unclaimed that would be your you know
your hawks and your you know eagles and
your vultures your swans it seems like
the only birds that were said to be
clean or what you would call the
foraging Birds those your birds your
pheasant pigeons now the ancient
chickens and turkeys were all in that
category and it is true they eat bugs
and stuff but a lot of fish eat bugs too
they're in the Clinton category they eat
bugs and they eat little fish so in
order for something to be clean it
wasn't required that it be a vegetarian
I think technically we know
the birds we know that are clean like
pigeons and sparrows and things they
strictly eat grains and seeds and the
chickens and turkeys don't in their
natural environment they don't eat that
so that's what I'm just saying like how
much should we use our own judgment oh
well I'm a vegetarian so I'll tell you
what my judgment is I don't eat any but
if a person is gonna eat meat I think
you ought to be wise about it and and
you know I it's not just what the
animals either mean just even the
conditions today you know one reason
that the world is having a coronavirus
scare right now and it is a real concern
is because people who are breeding
animals for food and sometimes exotic
animals in close contact got cold got
viruses exchanged with them that's also
how the SARS epidemic and Eve the oh the
bird flu and mm-hmm
it all comes from that the swine flu
that's where it gets its name so I think
people are a lot better off if we're not
breeding animals and masty devour them
so yeah I don't need chicken
I don't need Turkey but you were I think
you were biblically they did fit in the
clean category so you just got to be
honest about it they were in the
foraging category but not every bird not
every fish not every mammal is mentioned
in the Bible because there's thousands
of them so they give his principles okay
all right good good thought appreciate
that thanks so much you know we do have
a study guide others might have
questions about this we do have a study
guide it's called God's free health plan
and it talks about what does the Bible
say about food not just the cleaning on
the unclean animals but general health
principles that we can find in the Bible
or we'll be happy to send this to anyone
who calls and ask the number is 883 five
six seven four seven and again you just
ask for that study guide we'll be happy
to send it to you it's called God's free
health plan next caller that we have is
Angela listening in Tallahassee Florida
Angela welcome to the program listen to
you thank you every day on Facebook
and you know it just coronavirus scared
I just wanted to know um how does it
correlate with what the Bible saying
about the end times I mean yes a lot of
people are frightened by this um uh pre
how is it related doesn't mean it's not
Jesus is all this my thanks to earth
can you yes yeah no I'm glad you asked
that question I'll tell you a little a
little secret I told Karen before I left
the house tonight I said if nobody asks
me Karen callin that Karen has never
called in a Bible question in all these
years she said all don't know my voice I
said what they won't care call in ask me
about the coronavirus because someone is
thinking that I'm so glad that you
called in and now Karen's off the hook
well first of all you don't find
coronavirus in the Bible but what you do
find is the Bible says that there are
going to be plagues now let me read this
to you when the disciples Matthew 24
disciples are asking Jesus about the
last days and and he tells him look you
know it's not gonna happen just yet
verse 7 Matthew 24 verse 7 for nation
will rise against nation and Kingdom
against Kingdom and there will be
famines he's saying all around the world
through history there's going to be Wars
there's gonna be famines and then he
says pestilence that word pestilence is
the same as the word plague it's talking
about diseases and there can be caused
by microscopic you know agencies and and
this is what's happening with the
coronavirus is that we've had some
serious plagues before some of you in
California and other parts remember when
they had the West Nile virus got some
dear friends at one contracted that and
and then you've got the SARS and the the
Middle Eastern virus and the h1n1 flu
and there's still some very very
virulent dangerous flus that are out
there now some of them they've developed
some you know inoculations for and
vaccines but they may not get one
developed for the coronavirus for now
they say nine months or
year and places where it's hits it's
spreading and it does have a higher
percentage of death somewhere between
2.5 and 3 percent of those who
contracted died we're wondering because
you know without all the testing kids a
lot of people may have very light cases
of it they don't even know they've got
it
some children they've very very few
children are getting there for some
reason which is great that it's not
affecting the children so much but is it
a sign of the end well Jesus said
there's gonna be plagues is that one of
the seven last plagues no it's probably
going to have a profound impact on the
economy for at least this year because
it's heard China 20% of their trade is
down how we know it's affecting some
countries with tourism airlines right
now are and and cruises poor cruise
lines if you want to get a discount
cruise friends now is the time so is it
a sign of the ends yeah cause I think
these things will accelerate is the
virus itself a particular sign no
there's you know nowhere in prophecy
mentions this particular virus but
plagues pestilence is one of the signs
you know we do have that free study
guide talking about how that's called
God's free health plan and might not
specifically mention viruses but there
are some practical principles that the
Bible gives that I think it's wise for
us to be aware of and you know
recognizing that our bodies are a temple
of the Holy Spirit and we want to take
care of it the very best that we can and
we'll be happy to send it to anyone who
calls and asks it's eight hundred eight
thirty five six seven four seven and ask
for that study guide called God's free
health plan we've got Michael listening
in ontario's st. Catherine Michael wife
of the program hey how you doing doing
well thank you for calling yes I watch a
program I've been up to the BC Camp I I
appreciate the work that all the
truthers are doing god bless you thank
you so much and your your the question
tonight
the difference between the bible's is
very important I figured out for myself
the King James has a verse in Genesis
1:28 that says replenish the earth now
I'd like to bring it to attention that
there was a blob of water before the
explanation of the creation of Earth how
can we explain this said that there was
a one of water there's a flood you say
no there was water before the creation
of the earth before the explanation of
the creation of verse that's Genesis 1:2
through 11 right and but why do you
think that's a problem I mean you win
because Lucifer his name was in heaven
and Satan in the Garden of Eden and when
your name changes so does position and
time must pass so are you thinking that
the earth existed with the devil on it
before God made Adam and Eve I'm not
sure what you're saying so I now I would
respectfully say that when the word
replenish is use there that is a word
that really means to fill and in the
original I believe that a Hebrew was
often used to say fill the earth so it's
not like the earth had been decimated
and God wanted Adam and Eve to refill it
it's God made the earth tells us about
the six days he made it there were
certain elements when he you know it was
there and he had the elements of matter
and water and probably the some of the
various gases and and separated them
made the continents in the atmosphere
but I don't believe the Lucifer was down
to her on the earth ruling he had no
right to this planet until Adam and Eve
sinned says in Romans I think it's
chapter 6 it whoever you obey that's
whose servant you are and when man chose
to listen to the devil instead of God
Lucifer then was
he found a beachhead to continue his
rebellion against the Father so um yeah
I guess I don't I don't find the gap
theory in the Bible and so I hope you
can forgive us for respectfully
disagreeing with that mic thank you
though for your question appreciate it
next bullet that we have is Melvin
listening from Jersey City New Jersey
praise You Lord hey thank you for
calling yes the profits between our
literacy in the profits between hey guys
and and Rebecca pH and I Zephaniah how
you pronounce it again yeah Zephaniah is
one of the they call him a minor prophet
Melvin and he prophesied during the time
of it says in the days of Josiah the son
of a man king of Judah so he lived you
know during the time of this great king
you can see the time the break is
creeping up on us so I hope you'll
forgive his Melvin I'll pick up your
question when we come back
don't go away friends more questions
coming
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides plus a Bible
numbers and symbols charts and eight
pages of colorful maps this best-ever
Bible gives you a biblical cyclope dick
index words of Christ in red chronology
of the Old Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
what if you could know the future what
would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers see his death as a fulfillment
of salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking Bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com you're
listening to Bible answers live where
every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian life call us now
at 800-831-6273 hazekiah
who was also a prophet and he prophesied
during the time of Good King Josiah who
lived after bad King Manasseh and but it
wasn't long after the time of Josiah
that is some wicked a couple of wicked
Kings came in some of his sons and
eventually Jerusalem was destroyed so
Zephaniah probably was a contemporary of
the Prophet Habakkuk
and Jeremiah that prophesied before the
Babylonian captivity and what did he say
his name means the name means Yahweh has
hidden or Yahweh has treasured God has
hidden or his treasured and yep three
chapters in the book of Zephaniah and
that was I think a question Aaron had it
looks like we've lost his call
who's next pastor Roscoe Becky listening
from Michigan Becky welcome to the
program hello how you guys doing good
thank you for calling god bless you
yeah your question my having as a 4-1
decide was why was there so much
opposition why was he against his wife
rebuilding their temple in Jerusalem
well because they had been gone for 70
years and since the Israelites were
displaced it was a prime piece of land
and the the Samaritans and the Arabians
and these other kingdoms they were
treating it like it was theirs you know
when the Israelites left they left a lot
of farms and vineyards and orchards just
as it was Wells and and then you're kind
of all moved into it and when the
Israelites started moving back you know
they saw there's a mass migration they
didn't appreciate and that was one
reason another reason was when they
heard that they were going to build the
temple
there's no good we'll help you build it
we'll all worship together and they said
no your worship of God is very different
from our worship of God and then they
were insulted and they became their
enemies and so they opposed everything
they were doing from that point on they
just were so upset that the Israelites
had come back to take the land back
again and then we're having that in the
world today you know the Palestinians
are very upset that the Jews are coming
from different parts of the world and
saying you know we want this land back
again we were driven out nineteen
hundred years ago by the Romans but we
want it back well they say well you've
been gone that long it's not yours
anymore
and so they resent it and you're having
some of the same squabbles today they
had back after the Babylonian captivity
so good question Becky and you can see
this not only in the book of Ezra you
can see there's great opposition in the
book of Nehemiah as well when they tried
to build the walls thank you for your
call we've got next Coley's crews
listening from Bakersfield California
crews welcome to the program
thank you thank you for taking my call
yeah I just have a question when Jesus
said that he had to leave because he
says in my father's house there are many
mansions and I will go to prepare a room
for you so my question is is there like
a literal room and and but it also says
that we'll be able to build our own
homes that nobody we won't build for
anyone but ourselves but what if I would
just want to stay in that men
and not go out and build me at home
great great question you know and if you
want to just stay in the city home that
Jesus has prepared for you for a few
million years and then say now I think
I'll build a country home you're gonna
have eternity to think about it so don't
worry
now when Jesus used that language we
often say you know I got a mansion over
the hilltop the original word it is
dwelling place it doesn't say mansion
and the way we say it in English and
Jesus is using the language of a Jewish
wedding he's basically saying you know
when a when a Jewish girl accepted a
proposal from a Jewish man they make a
wedding covenant then they didn't get
married right away he would then go
prepare a wedding chamber on his
father's house and when it was complete
he would come and receive his bride
that's the parable of the ten virgins
and the parable of the wedding feast and
there's several parables where he uses
marriage language so this is what Christ
is saying is I'm gonna come back from my
bride and but he'll have a city home in
the New Jerusalem are these mansions
he's dwelling places that he's prepared
keep in mind the Bible tells us the
dimensions of the New Jerusalem are
about 350 miles square now New York City
I'll give you an amazing fact the
dallas-fort Worth Airport has more land
than Manhattan just the airport in
Dallas has more land than Manhattan and
Manhattan's got eight million people so
if you think about a city 350 miles
square 1,500 miles around plenty of room
for everybody and he's going to build
these beautiful dwelling places there
but we'll go forth from the New
Jerusalem it mentions in Malachi 4 and
we will plant houses Isaiah says and
inhabit them and plant vineyards and
build them we'll build houses and
inhabit and plant vineyards orchard so
forth I want to go to other planets and
get vacation homes and other universes
or galaxies that would be fun but then
also it would be fun to stay in that
mansion because that's where God dwells
the Father and Jesus that's right that's
right and it's gonna be so good coming
home it will go out we're gonna go
through the cosmos and tell everybody
what Jesus has done for
and then we'll come back and worship
them and I don't think we're gonna need
a UFO I'm not sure how we're getting
around but I think we're gonna be able
to travel really fast
I'm not mention where we all be able to
live there at me from the beginning of
time of Adam and Eve to the end of time
when Jesus comes again for us well I
mean there'd be enough room in that
mansion for all the people of all the
generations oh yes housing you know if
everybody on earth and I keep in mind
we've got about 7.5 billion people on
earth today seven point four billion
there's more there's enough room in the
New Jerusalem for like 20 billion people
that's probably more people than I've
ever lived unfortunately most people are
not saved so there's plenty of room in
the kingdom of God for everybody and of
course if for some reason it happens to
be a little small I think God there's no
problem with God expanding the city you
know how you blow up a basketball you
just you put that air pump pumping it
God can just pump the world up make a
bigger more surface area he can do
anything he wants all right well thank
you for your call Cruz we've got Bob
listening in Walla Walla Bob welcome to
the program hi Pastor us good to have
you back thank you you're welcome
yes I was calling about forever in
Exodus there's a couple places that
talks about forever Exodus 28 43 talks
about the priest or something doing
something forever and then then Nexis
3117 it talks about keeping the Sabbath
forever so if forever is forever then
how does one have an ending and one
doesn't well which one do you think has
an ending the priests were it that they
do not incur iniquity and die it should
be a step to forever
to him and his descendants after him
well it would still be true that you
know if if there were Jewish priests
today that they would still you know
maintain that holiness some of the some
of the statements that God made in the
covenant to the Israelites we're
actually there you know God gave a
spiritual analogy later for example to
covenant of circumcision it says is
forever but Paul said you know once
Jesus died on the cross now we're
talking about circumcision of the heart
so you would be wondering then why does
God say the seventh day is a sign
forever
and there's there's nothing - that would
interfere there's no substitute for
needing physical rest every seventh day
and that time of worship that makes them
so you know it's to go on forever
circumcision was and you know one of the
ways that I also understand this the
Sabbath day existed before there was sin
so it's part of this eternal perfect
plan and we're going to keep it again in
heaven Isaiah 66 so the Sabbath is part
of his perfect plan circumcision and
certain laws about the priests all came
after sin because of sin when Christ
comes are you know even with this first
coming these things want to be necessary
anymore
Paul says circumcision is nothing
uncircumcision is nothing but keeping
the commandments is what matters you
know we do have a study guy called the
last day in history and people might be
wondering about though what is the
Sabbath day all about is it important
for us today we'll be happy to send you
this study guide it free all you left to
do is ask for it the number is 883 five
six seven four seven and again just ask
for this study guide it's called the
last day of history and I think you'll
find it a fascinating study if you've
never looked into what the Bible has to
say on the subject next caller the
behave is Emanuel listening from Africa
an international call Emmanuel welcome
to the program
doing good and how's your question in
there
well please my question tonight is in
mark Gospel chapter five there were
demon-possessed man and nowadays he was
mad and nowadays when I look at one
there are multiple around I think about
them a lot so imagine how they want to
be see because they grow really not
normal human beings so yeah how can
people be saved if they're um you know
acting demon-possessed you see there is
still demon possession today and the
Lord does still deliver people from teen
monic possession it's usually in
response to prayer it may be their
prayers and it may be the intervention
of others and it may be both this man in
mark chapter five who is saved from the
devil's - things are happening one Jesus
is there he's come to see him and the
man came to Christ in spite of the
problem that he was being tormented by
Devils it says he came and worshipped
him so the man knew he had a problem the
devil's don't want to worship him but
what was left of the man inside knew
that he needed God's help and but when
he opened his mouth the devil spoke yeah
there are all kinds of people in the
world today that are being influenced by
the devil everybody is harassed by the
devil
some people are harassed more than
others some are possessed some it might
be something small this man in the Bible
he was possessed by a legion of demons
and he was in pretty bad shape running
around naked in the mountains living in
a cave where the dead bodies and
surrounded by pigs and covered by chains
and breaking chains with his
supernatural power he is exhibit a mark
5 is Exhibit A of the most hopeless lost
dirty man in the Bible so but good Jesus
saved him so you can save anybody and I
got a book I wrote about this called
broken chains and a matter of fact I
have a sermon about it online people to
watch for free just type in Doug
Batchelor broken chains and you'll see
that message Emmanuel and thank you for
calling and good morning to you in
Africa next one of the behalf is another
international caller we have Joe calling
from Guam
I guess not officially international but
a long way away welcome Joe thank you
thank you yeah yeah Thank You mr.
bachelor for taking my call
I have a quick question - do we
recognize our loved ones in the Haven
yeah thank you but these yes please give
me the scripture well one would be first
Corinthians chapter 13 it says now I
know in part and this is verse 12 but
then I shall know even as I am known so
when we get to heaven the simple
question is are we going to have better
discernment and perception or less even
though grandma in heaven is gonna have a
new glorified body she may not be
hunched over with wrinkles we are gonna
have spiritual discernment in heaven
that will be enhanced we're gonna
immediately know who grandma is and so I
think absolutely we will recognize each
other in it probably we'll know each
other even better than we do now because
we're going to have enhanced spiritual
powers right now or confined to two
dimensions but we'll be so spirit led
then and we'll recognize their spirit
and and who they are even though they've
got a physical body well know who they
are by the essence of them so yeah you
know pastors like we have that book
called heaven is it for real and I think
it will deal with the head same question
again we'll be happy to send this to
anyone in North America the number is
883 five six seven four seven and asked
for the book called heaven is it for
real and Joe you can read it online
since you're in Guam we can't mail it to
you right yeah go to the amazing facts
website next photo that we have is June
listening from Florida June welcome to
the program
hey do and you're on the air you I hear
the radio in the background so you may
have walked away from the phone June
going once
June going twice are you there yes hi
thank you hi yes thank you so much
pastor dark and you may want to turn off
the radio in the background or you'll
get confused by the time delay
yes yeah yes yes I am and your question
yes thank you we can hear the radio
there so your question Jun well
well here's a question I have going to
church on Saturday something happened
okay okay I'm sorry
yes going to church on Saturday
something something happened like it was
so hard for people actually to to hug
each other or you know we always
fellowship on Saturday we hug we
handshake now it seems like people are
so scared to actually fellowship I was
supposed to be fear or scared that the
corner virus may have a negative impact
on the Christian as Jesus said that when
in the time of Moses that they were
protected even the plagues were on Egypt
but they were not feed because God had
their back had protected them I was
supposed to be scared today for the
corner virus when you go to church to
actually shake hand oh yeah that's good
question you know we had this same
experience this weekend you know we got
together and everyone has been so
hypersensitive because probably 20 times
a day we're all hearing wash your hands
do not touch your face if you around
anybody sick and you know they're very
concerned Public Health people are very
concerned about spreading us of course
all of that is good practical Christian
sanitation Moses in the Levitical laws
was one of the first ones to talk about
washing when you touch something
contaminated or being separated from
others if you know quarantine if someone
was unclean and so some of these laws of
Sanitation go all the way back to Moses
there's nothing wrong with that and so
if there's an out
if people want to be a little more
careful that's probably prudent now you
know it's during flu season it's always
a good idea because this is a virus to
practice the same prevention you would
work for the flu fact I've heard some
say that this may be a better flu season
than others because people are so
careful now with sanitation that the
regular flu virus is not touching as
many people since this scare so I don't
know if that's true or not but I that's
kind of an adult information I've heard
but it doesn't mean it's a lack of faith
if you're living in a high-risk area if
I was in Yunnan China or in northern
Italy right now
yeah I'd recommend the members don't hug
each other Italians do a lot of hugging
and kissing and you go to France I've
never been kissed so much Argentina some
of these places so yeah you've got to be
careful and I think you know when this
passes people can probably resume being
a little more you know congenial and
demonstrative but yeah folks I stood at
the door yesterday and I shake hands
just like I always do and I just be
careful not to touch my eyes or my face
and I use sanitizer when I'm done so
yeah it's not a lack of faith to
practice sanitation and common sense
anyway yeah yes so if you're if you're
in an area that's low risk or there's no
cases of it then you're probably just as
safe as you've always been mm-hmm you
know past that are just talking about
that we have a couple of our church
members who are the one is the ER nurse
and I was talking to them at church and
I guess they had a patient that came in
actually one of the people that passed
away from this coronavirus right here in
the Sacramento area and he said you know
we just do the best we can we wear the
gloves we wear the you know the mask or
whatever we have to do when I work with
these patients and then we leave it in
the Lord's hands mm-hmm and I think
that's practical advice you do the best
you can and then don't worry you can't
live in fear
put it back to ants he's gonna take care
of you exactly well thank you appreciate
your question June next color that we
have is salsa I believe
listening from bakersfield soci welcome
to the program thank you very much
you're taking my call my question is
[Music]
John chapter 5 verses 16 and 17 can you
please explain those two verses for me
apparently there is a thing that leads
to that right well of course the penalty
for all sin is death but John is saying
if anyone let me read it it's verse 16
and 17 at first John chapter 5 if anyone
sees his brother sending the sin which
does not lead to death he will ask and
he will give him life for those who
commit sin that is not leading to death
there is a sin leading to death I do not
say that he should pray about that you
know you would think well what would you
not pray about
I guess he's talking about that if
someone has grieved the way the Holy
Spirit and committed the unpardonable
sin praying about that may not help but
I would think every other person unless
they haven't committed the pardonable
unpardonable sin Christians would want
to witness to pray for intercede for
mediate for people that are trying to
find salvation that are still they still
have hope so the sin that leads to death
that he's talking about here I think
he's talking about the unpardonable sin
that make sense now we've got a book
yeah absolutely and associate if you
like we have a book that deals with that
and it's called what is the unpardonable
sin I believe we cover this first in
that book and you will enjoy it or
anybody that wants to know more about
the subject the number to call is 883
five six seven four seven and again just
after the book what is the unpardonable
sin and we'll send it to you if you in
North America otherwise you can read it
for free online but just going to the
amazing facts website we've got crystal
listening in Florida Crystal welcome to
the program thank you for asking like
for a man your shelter I have a question
we had a Bible study and he said that
immortal life is conditional you have to
eat the fruit tree of life through the
life when you go to heaven to have
eternal life
but away I understand on 1st Corinthians
15 that when Jesus comes I'm mortal to
be in mortality and death would be
thrown I know it doesn't be a sting so
why is it immortal and why is that
conditional well I believe that we have
eternal life when Christ comes and when
the righteous when we get our glorified
bodies and that doesn't mean we won't be
eating from the tree of life because
Revelation chapter or what is it chapter
22 says that there is the tree of life
in the new earth and we will eat from
that tree once again and we have real
bodies in heaven you know right now
we've lost our spiritual dimension some
people say well we're gonna just be
spirits up there but the Bible is very
clear we're gonna have real bodies
Christ when he rose from the dead he ate
in front of the disciples on three two
occasions that I can think of and so we
will eat from the tree of life there
will be benefits from that that help to
maintain the you know the eternal
vitality or re-energize us I'm not sure
but says we're gonna plant vineyards and
eat the fruit of them so we still eat we
still drink in heaven we're gonna drink
the water well I believe that to
understand conditional I just never
figured that be conditional or we'll
have eternal life and it's it's
unconditional at that point I mean once
we're saved were saved for eternity
that's why I got yeah so in heaven it's
not that God takes away our freedom but
sin will not rise up the second time and
that's in the book
Nahum is a chapter to ya sin affliction
will not rise up again the second time
Thank You crystal appreciate your call
hope that helps a little bit
next photo that we have is Mike
listening from Massachusetts Mike
welcome to the program hi hi Mike here
we've got two minutes can we do this
quickly yes I think we can so my
question concerns character and the
question is do we have to reach the
point of overcoming all sin do we have
to be perfect before Christ's second
coming and where does grace as I
interesting in the bridge between
humanity's in perfect state in heaven
you know fit
you know the transformation of our
character it's that take place before is
coming do our nature's have to be pure
and holy well live in by the prize yeah
let me jump in here of course we need to
have the mind of Christ and the Bible
tells us in Hebrews that we need to
strive for holiness without which no one
will see God and just as Jesus said
blessed are the pure in heart they will
see God
so how perfect do we need to be we need
to love the Lord the same way that
Daniel loved the Lord so that he would
not deny him but he said I'll go to the
lion's den kind of love that Shadrach
Meshach and Abednego said I'm not gonna
pray to graven images we love the Lord
we want to honor him and the great
command that love the Lord with all your
heart mind soul and strength but the
real question you're asking is who out
there feels like they're perfect enough
nobody
so how perfect do you need to be to be
saved we've got a book we're gonna offer
cuz I don't have time to finish me so
the book is can you live without sinning
great book by Joe Cruz I hope everybody
go to the website and look that up don't
let the title scare you it's a great
book is it possible to live without
sinning and just go to amazing facts dot
o-r-g Mike I hope that helps a little
bit and for our friends that are
listening it wouldn't be fair to you in
the remaining thirty eight seconds of
our live time together to take another
call we hope you'll give us a chance we
see you standing there
Tia and Vicky and Gayle and Carl and Lea
we're so sorry we didn't get to your
calls tonight give us a call again next
week and friends if you are blessed by
this program if you're instructed or
encouraged it's where a hundred percent
supported by folks like you listening
you can go to amazing facts and just
click donate keep us on your station
thank you so much and God bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts International
a faith-based ministry located in
Granite Bay California
[Music]
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides plus a Bible
numbers and symbols chart and eight
pages of colorful maps this best-ever
Bible gives you a biblical cyclope dick
index words of Christ in red chronology
of the Old Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five three eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five can't get enough amazing facts
Bible study you don't have to wait until
next week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vo RG DT no amazing backs has
a free Bible school that you can do from
the comfort of your own home it includes
27 beautifully illustrated study lessons
to aid in your study of God's Word
sign up today for this free Bible study
course by calling 184 205 7000 that's
one eight four four two one five 7,000
[Music]
for life-changing Christian resources
visit AF bookstore calm
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our website at
www.ge.com which offers thousands of
inspiring books DVDs and more to help
you get the most out of God's Word to
take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast call us at
[Music]
you're listening to an encore
presentation of Bible answers live the
phone number to join the program and ask
your questions is not available this
evening however if you want to order any
materials offered during tonight's
program you may call our resource number
anytime at